este vídeo le ayudará a comprender qué
es un accidente cerebrovascular y el
riesgo de sufrir uno
normalmente los vasos sanguíneos
llamados arterias llevan sangre al
cerebro
el cerebro necesita un flujo constante
de sangre para obtener el oxígeno y los
nutrientes que necesita para funcionar
correctamente durante un accidente
cerebrovascular también conocido como
ataque cerebral el flujo de sangre a una
parte del cerebro se ha detenido el tipo
más común de accidente cerebrovascular
se llama accidente cerebrovascular
isquémico puede ocurrir en una arteria
donde una sustancia grasa llamada placa
ha estrechado la arteria
en un tipo de accidente cerebrovascular
isquémico llamado accidente
cerebrovascular trombótico la placa se
puede romper y formar un coágulo de
sangre que bloquea el flujo de sangre al
cerebro
en otro tipo de accidente
cerebrovascular isquémico llamado
accidente cerebrovascular embólico un
coágulo de sangre se forma en otra área
del cuerpo y viaja a través del torrente
sanguíneo si llega a una arteria cercana
o al cerebro puede bloquear el flujo de
sangre
cuando una arteria una parte del cerebro
se bloquea durante un accidente
cerebrovascular el oxígeno y los
nutrientes en la sangre no pueden llegar
a esas células cerebrales las células
comienzan a morir en minutos
un tipo menos común de accidente
cerebrovascular se llama accidente
cerebrovascular hemorrágico ocurre
cuando un vaso sanguíneo debilitado se
rompe y filtra sangre al cerebro esto
bloquea el flujo de sangre al cerebro y
la sangre que gotea ejerce presión sobre
el tejido cerebral produciendo un daño
al cerebro
en un ataque isquémico transitorio ait
un coágulo bloquea el flujo de sangre al
cerebro
sin embargo es diferente de los otros
tipos de accidente cerebrovascular
porque el coágulo se rompe después de un
corto tiempo los ataques isquémicos
transitorios generalmente no causan
ningún daño permanente
la presión arterial alta es el principal
factor de riesgo para cualquier tipo de
accidente cerebrovascular otros factores
de riesgo incluyen la diabetes
ciertos tipos de enfermedades cardíacas
el tabaquismo
nivel de colesterol alto
y previos ataques isquémicos
transitorios
es importante conocer estos signos y
síntomas de un accidente cerebrovascular
un entumecimiento repentino o debilidad
en su cara brazos y piernas
especialmente si está ubicado en un lado
de su cuerpo confusión repentina y
dificultad para hablar o no poder
comprender a los demás cuando hablan
problemas repentinos en la visión en uno
o ambos ojos mareos repentinos pérdida
del equilibrio o no poder caminar y un
dolor de cabeza repentino y severo
llame al 911 de inmediato si cree que
usted o alguien más puede estar
sufriendo un accidente cerebrovascular
para obtener más información sobre su
riesgo de sufrir un accidente
cerebrovascular hablé con su proveedor
de atención médica